all misses is at home  doing all of those things  that it that is work it you know it's  not that's not light it's not easy right  you know that is something to be  respected and valued yeah I'd say a 10  minute touch up is not that deep though  yeah I mean I mean I'm not yeah okay  what but but still it's it's an effort  she's she's making an effort to look  after herself so that you can come in  and receive this you know this this  effort that she's made but not not only  that but the other things you know don't  just throw chicken wings in the in the  oven but actually plan the meal prepare  the meal someone else was talking uh  earlier on on the part about  um having a nice clean house to come  back to so if she's doing all of those  that's work that is that is